[Musique]
non
les rams de los angeles et les bengals
de cincinnati vont s'affronter dans le
cadre du 56ème super bowl et plus de 100
millions d'américains qui vont regarder
le match et les publicités une publicité
de 30 secondes coûte en moyenne 6
millions 500 mille dollars américains
ray lalonde experts en marketing sportif
ancien dirigeant des canadiens des
alouettes est avec nous ce soir bonsoir
il à londres bonsoir général alors
retour à la normale pour et on dira
d'abord pour le superbowl qui aura pas
de limitation d'assistance contrairement
à ce qu'on a vu dans le passé qu'est ce
qui est particulier cette année ben
c'est un retour à la normale comme te
dis puis surtout le fait de jouer à los
angele pour les rams externe chrome qui
alors les rams ont construit un stade au
coût de 5 points 5 milliards de dollars
si la première saison à capacité avec
des spectateurs dans le stade et ça se
termine avec les browns qui accueille le
super bowl et que leurs équipes
participent c'est du jamais vu la
première fois de l'histoire c'était l'an
dernier alors que les buckeyes avait
joué à tampa bay devant lopez alors
c'est un grand stade 70000 spectateurs
est ce que c'est un record non le record
c'était en 1980 le super bowl 14 à
pasadena en californie sans 3985
spectateurs c'est pas une question de
capacité mais ce stade là c'est vraiment
ce que j'appelle gerald un vaisseau
spatial un bijou dans les stades
mondiaux vous avez prononcé le nom de
stanstead mikron qui c'est qui
c'est un maniaque de l'immobilier mais
je crois sincèrement que c'est le plus
grand propriétaire de sport sur la
planète pour la simple raison qu'elle
lui seul il détient les nuggets de la
nba l'avalanche de la ligue nationale
les rapides de la mls les browns de la
nfl et l'arsenal dans la première ligue
aucun individu à part une entreprise un
conglomérat ne détient autant de
propriétés sportives sur la planète et
on comprend qu'il est extrêmement riche
la wii absolument c'est lui qui a payé
son stade de plus de 5 milliards de
dollars lui même il n'y avait pas de
débat il ya bâtisse à inglewood en
californie pour évidemment contribuer au
retour de la nfl en californie qu'il a
payé lui-même son stade
la payer lui-même centre est intéressant
un bon modèle pour ceux qui sont
intéressés d'avoir des équipes sportives
bay wipix si ça peut marcher bien sûr
absolument le super bowl c'est quand
même un incroyable événement c'est
probablement l'événement annuel des
meilleures publicités
on en a montré quelques unes mais encore
cette année il y en a des tonnes se
représente convient aux revenus
publicitaires
nbc cette année gerald frappe le gros
lot parce que ils ont les jeux
olympiques puis entre les deux lors du
week-end entre les deux semaines ils ont
le super bowl alors il c'est une
domination totale de nbc ce match là va
générer 500 millions $ us en revenus
publicitaires ça monte à chaque année il
ya un engouement pour les annonceurs
cette année de revenir c'est le retour
de budweiser les clouds elle comme on le
voit et ça c'est quelque chose
d'important c'est qu'on veut vraiment
profiter de ces 100 millions et plus de
téléspectateurs ou de consommateurs sur
les plateformes rejoindre ces gens-là
connectés avec leurs marques parfois
lancé tu as ton propre produit est
engagé ces gens là alors évidemment
c'est le plus grand effort publicitaire
sur la planète et des crypto monnaie en
publicité cette année crypto monnaie
ensuite de salé paris sportifs tout ce
qui est technologique évidemment des
marques plus traditionnelles qui ont
déjà été dans le super bon mais ça me
rappelle un peu l'arrivée des dot com le
ya une vingtaine d'années où tous aller
vers le super bowl que ce soit godaddy
que ce soit pète points comme pour
lancer leurs produits blancs yeux un
essoufflement mais là on revient de plus
fort avec l'économie technologie et
c'est important soit parce que c'est
l'avenir de notre société de
consommation donc la publicité et
spectacle de la mi temps que représente
le spectacle de la mi temps encore
aujourd'hui il ya deux particularités
gerald d'abord c'est pepsi qui présente
encore une fois il ya des annonceurs qui
sont présents mais ce sont des idées
divertisseurs des idées des chanteurs
des performances de leurs 32 snoop dogg
dr dre eminem alors une nouvelle
génération ciblé par leur présence et je
répète à tout le monde que ces artistes
là ne sont pas payés pour performer mais
profite de l'opportunité eux aussi
d'être devant 100 millions de
téléspectateurs alors c'est le plus gros
show puis les audiences télé toujours
lors de ce spectacle la mutation pas
ceux du match pourquoi parce que tout le
monde veut voir le spectacle à mi temps
effectivement pourquoi le super bowl se
démarque temps quand on regarde un
paquet d'événements sportifs qui peuvent
exister celui-là est particulier
pourquoi ben moi je pense que il ya deux
raisons d'abord c'est le summum de ce
qu'on appelle le sport business tout ce
qu'il ya de plus gros et plus grand et
plus riche et plus d'argent de plus
spectaculaire ça se déroule au super
bowl on parle de publicité on parle de
prix des billets on parle du stade qui a
coûté une fortune on parle des audiences
télé 75 des 100 meilleures émissions
regardées dans l'histoire de la télé
américaine sont des marches le football
de la nfl et évidemment tous les super
bon alors c'est le rendez vous dont six
convois et divertit puis l'autre chose
c'est que pour le reste du monde c'est
un symbole de l'amérique ce que
j'appelle l'américaine on regarde le
super bowl on comprends pas trop le
match puis le jeu c'est complexe le
football américain mais on regarde parce
que c'est l'amérique qui est symbolisé
ce jour c'est combien billets mais le
billet le moins cher en date de ce matin
gérard 3519 dollars savary vers le bloc
plus on est patient plus on attend
jusqu'à dimanche pour ceux qui seraient
intéressés mais ils vont avoir un
meilleur prix mais évidemment les gens
lorsqu'on achetait ya quelques semaines
payé 9 10 mille dollars puis mercredi
j'en ai vu à 46 mille dollars chaque
billet donc encore une fois grosse
dépense mais ça vaut le coup on a parlé
de tout sauf du jeu le football en soi
mais il reste quinze secondes qui gagne
les bengals de cincinnati
ça va être une surprise ça va ils sont
les négligés mais ils ont une carrière
qui s'appelle giorgio d'euros qui lui a
du courage puis ce qu'on appelle des
couilles pour aller battre une équipe
comme les rams dans leur domicile alors
j'ai confiance au bingo parfait pour
cerep là-dessus merci beaucoup oui la
dre du géra lui pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit
oh